miles de personas están acudiendo a cabo
cañaveral para tener la oportunidad de
presenciar este lunes el despegue del
vuelo de prueba no tripulado de la
misión artemis esta será la primera de
una serie de lanzamientos que esperan
llevar a los astronautas a la luna por
primera vez desde 1972
desde el transbordador espacial
realmente no ha habido nada tan
importante y volver a la luna qué
emocionante es eso no puedo esperar ya
para tener una misión tripulada a la
luna friday artemis también quiere
desbloquear otro hito pretende poner a
la primera mujer y a la primera persona
afro en la superficie lunar el objetivo
final de la misión afirma la nasa es el
próximo salto gigante la exploración
humana de marte nos gustaría realizar
misiones humanas en la superficie de la
luna y alrededor de ella seguidas de
misiones a marte usando una enfoque de
acumulación gradual
nos gustaría demostrar tecnologías y
operaciones para vivir y trabajar en una
superficie planetaria que no sea la
tierra
la misión inaugural de este lunes verdad
es pegar hacia el espacio a un cohete de
98 metros en lugar de humanos habrá
maniquí de alta tecnología llenos de
sensores y solamente orbitarán en la
luna antes de volver a la tierra el
aterrizaje real está programado para
2025 durante la tercera entrega de la
misión pero algunos expertos señalan que
artemis 3 podrían obtener lugar hasta
2026 spacex la compañía espacial del
multimillonario y lo más que construirá
el módulo de aterrizaje para artemis 3
después de que su empresa fuera elegida
sobre el blue origin propiedad de jeff
bezos